autre interrogation poste confinement la
question du second tour des municipales
aura-t-il lieu en juin ou en janvier
2021 sur la question et loire philippe a
rencontré hier soir à les chefs des
partis politiques le premier ministre
doit faire connaître sa position avant
samedi
si plusieurs responsables politiques
appellent à ne pas précipiter les choses
d'autres souhaitent organiser le scrutin
le plus rapidement possible c'est
compliqué d'organiser une élection
sincères sont rencontre entre candidats
et électeurs
cela risque d'éliminer tout débat
démocratique avec une campagne
particulière sans réunions publiques
sans distribution de tracts une partie
de l'électorat au rappeur de voter à
partir du moment où les conditions
sanitaires sont réunies je suis
favorable à ce que les élections se
tiennent le plus rapidement possible et
notamment en juin s'il n'est pas
possible de faire une campagne
électorale
un scrutin ne peut pas avoir lieu deux
blocages pour juin un blocage sanitaire
parce qu'on n'a pas encore le bilan du
déconfinement et un blocage démocratique
les français ne sont pas prêts à aller
voter après le fiasco du premier tour il
n'y aura pas de campagne il y aura très
peu de participation c'est très partagée
dans tous les partis
chez nous c'est du 50 50 on souhaite que
les élections se tiennent le plus tôt
possible
c'est très difficile de se prononcer
dans la mesure où eux ont accès à des
informations que nous nous n'avons pas
neuf jours après le thé confinement il
est encore trop tôt pour dire si oui ou
non on pourra voter le 28 juin